very different I was looking at Lee only
last week because of the anniversary to
see how different it was and it's just
incredible to see that pre-crisis
Northern Rock was growing its balance
sheet hugely fast went from 25 billion
pounds to 100 billion pounds in the
space divided and I 2 and a half years
on limited capital and high wholesale
funding and you know from our
perspective we're a much smaller bank
with much more capital and almost all of
our funding comes from the retail market
so you know absolutely transformed from
the bank that Northern Rock was Virgin
Money today is smaller safer sounder and
part of the the regulations that have
come in based on the regulations that
have come in since all of the crisis
happened one of the great things about
Northern Rock was that its identity was
very very closely tied up with the
northeast of England and Newcastle in
particular how much of that have you
been able to retain at Virgin Money when
we when we first bought Northern Rock I
was worried that the people there might
resent us a bit actually because the
Virgin brand was coming in and the
Northern Rock brand was going but
actually they welcomed us with open arms
both the staff and the community there
and as a result you know so much of what
we've achieved has been achieved based
on that the hard work and efforts of the
people of the Northeast what do you
think the biggest lessons that we
learned from the crisis were well I do
think that in the decades since the
crisis there's just been a huge amount
of progress made more capital more
liquidity more accountability I think we
should remember when the crisis happened
people were worried about their savings
because there wasn't any sort of
guarantee that they would be protected
and there of course around 80,000 pounds
worth of people savings in each Bank are
guaranteed for customers and I think
that's a really important thing to think
about I think underwriting standards
ever impute have improved enormous Lee
and so who knows in the future what
might happen but what I can say is that
the system that I operate in today is
materially stronger and better protected
than it was 10 years ago do you think
the crisis has done lasting damage to
consumer confidence in the financial
services sector
I hope not I mean of course the the
crisis in itself did mean that there was
a material reduction in trust in in
banks and I hope that that's being
rebuilt by all people that are involved
in the banking sector there's so much
more focused on making the system secure
and giving customers the products that
they rightly want and properly should
have and I think over time that means
that trust will be rebuilt and you know
it's beholden on every all of us that
work in the sector to make sure that
that is the case that we are operate
with integrity that we offer great
products and that we deserve the trust
that customers put in us